President Trump has been railing against
the new york times since the 2016
campaign claiming they were dishonest
and biased against him it turns out he
was right according to its former
executive editor Jill Abramson
she says the papers news pages the home
of it's straight news coverage have
become quote unmistakeably anti-trump
end quote
here now is howard kurtz fox news media
analyst and host of media buzz here on
the Fox News Channel and Howie thanks so
much for Christ you were the one that
broke this story and found that what
she's been saying but this is it I mean
we've heard this before but we haven't
really seen it to this day well we
haven't heard it from the former editor
of The New York Times the story's going
absolutely viral since I broke it in my
Fox column it's trending on Twitter
that's a big deal and Jill Abramson it's
in a forthcoming book called merchants
of truth and she says the news pages not
the op-ed land the news pages anti-trump
raw opinion in some stories and
headlines and that this ring is the cash
registers here's another quote given
it's mostly liberal audience there was
an implicit financial reward for the
times of running lots of Trump stories
almost all of them negative they drove
big traffic numbers more than a half
million digital subscriptions just the
first few months with Trump moving into
the White House yeah so they were
rewarded with circulation but at what
point did they get off the rails and
decide that hey we have got to go out
there and make sure we give our audience
what they want rather than playing it
straight and delivering the news why is
it that their mantra well that should be
the launcher of every news organization
but I think a lot of organizations like
The Times are finding that there is a
financial reward in almost a business
model in playing to an anti-trump
audience now in this case yes Jameson
was fired four years ago she writes
about this in the book I write about it
in the column she admits that she had
flaws she could be self-righteous he was
a flawed manager and she's criticizing
her successor Dean back pay the current
executive editor who was her number -
who did play a role in her firing but it
doesn't read to me like sour grapes she
praises them at times it reads to me
like somebody who loves the New York
Times who by the way is not a fan of
President Trump she's criticized them in
her own columns but she believes that
the paper that she love has just gone
off the rails when it comes to this
president now is there a term is there a
change
in the journalistic standards of the
young people I want to put up this quote
here that she's she's out she says the
more woke staff thought that urgent
times called for urgent measures the
dangers of Trump's presidency it yes so
I mean they they're so they're they
think they're self-righteous had
justified in doing this because there's
a greater good and I have heard so many
journalists say this some publicly some
privately that you know Donald Trump his
presidency is so out of control he's
he's so unfit for the job and all of
that that it justifies what we're doing
that in effect we become what Steve
Madden wants called the opposition party
that we have to crusade against him and
in Abramson's telling about the times
she says it's the younger staff the more
woke staff that feels like that you know
all that standards that we use for every
other president throw him out the window
because this is Donald Trump and then
she says the more anti trying top Trump
the ties is perceived to be the war it
was mistrusted for being biased and
that's the cost you make make lots of
money in the short term but if you lose
that credibility that you're just
applying a whole different set of
standards to a president who don't like
personally viscerally ideologically I
think your credibility gradually erodes
into larger audience and even the
relationship that she had with Hillary
Clinton I mean because it wasn't all-pro
Hillary Clinton I mean the New York
Times did break the story about the
email server the private email server
and that caused some distrust and she
seemed at least from what I read in your
article to say well that was a problem
for her well she says that she's never
gotten along with Hillary she says
Hillary could be paranoid she also
thinks The Times overplayed the Hillary
story that's been the subject of a lot
of debate since 2016 but the point is
you know this is not me saying it you
saying if President Trump saying and
this is a former editor of the paper
former Washington bureau chief former
Wall Street Journal reporter putting her
thoughts into this book and essentially
saying you know that the the critics of
the worst critics of the times are true
when it comes to the Trump coverage and
I think journalists at all organizations
have to worry at this point not that
there shouldn't be aggressive reporting
now there aren't smart reporters at the
Times not that some of the
investigations missed the mark but the
cumulative tone and volume in relent
this nature of the anti-trump fusillade
I think is really hurting credibility
and now we have July baby no likey go to
fox news comm you can find this article
that you put out there it is a
fascinating read and I do think it's
more problematic than just the New York
Times and I wonder where these schools
of journalism are and what they're
teaching these kids because I don't get
the sense of we're gonna report the news
not try to create the news to push our
own political narrative so thank you how
are you somehow that's now seen as
old-fashioned thank you exactly exactly
appreciate it